chaos an der türkisch-griechischen
grenze tausende migranten versuchen in
die eu zu kommen
vor lesbos stirbt dabei ein kind wie
umgehen mit corona experten stufen die
infektionsgefahr höher ein als zuletzt
die bundesregierung mahnt zur
besonnenheit und wachsamkeit klimakiller
digitalisierung umweltministerin schulze
forderte smartphones die länger leben
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nahm die in allen
zu einer neuen nachrichten woche heute
um 7 mit dem sport natürlich und kristin
otto hallo und knapp was sich da im
moment an der grenze zwischen der türkei
und griechenland abspielt ist eine
herausforderung für europa und das sieht
nicht so aus als sei europa auf diese
herausforderung vorbereitet
hunderte flüchtlinge und migranten
versuchen in die eu zu gelangen
griechische grenzschützer setzten
tränengas ein und blendgranaten
gleichzeitig plant die eu mehrere
krisentreffen
schauen wir uns mal die zusammenhänge an
das umkämpfte idlib kurz hinter der
türkischen grenze zu syrien und die
türkische grenze zur eu wo sich jetzt
die flüchtlinge drängen
dazwischen liegen rund 1400 kilometer
trotzdem hängen beide krisen zusammen
denn weil präsident erdogan sich im
kampf gegen syrische truppen von der eu
in stich gelassen fühlt hat er die
türkischen grenzen zu öffnen lassen
nicht nur fünf nicht für die flüchtlinge
von eclipse die sitzen in syrien fest
aber potenziell für die rund 3,6
millionen syrischen kriegsflüchtlinge
die seit jahren in der türkei leben
wie viele von ihnen sich jetzt exakt auf
gemacht haben ist unklar dominik
löschmeister noch immer machen sich
flüchtlinge auf dem weg in richtung
grenze sie kommen zu fuß mit dem bus
oder mit dem taxi
doch vor der griechischen seite geht es
nicht weiter mit tränengas und
blendgranaten werden die menschen
gestoppt nur wenigen gelingt es über die
zäune zu kommen werden sie gefasst geht
es zurück
die polizei hat uns erwischt sie haben
uns geschlagen und hierher gebracht
griechenland hat seine asylrecht
ausgesetzt die festgenommenen sollen
kein bleiberecht bekommen die
griechische küstenwache kompromisslos
warnschüsse gegen ein flüchtlingsboot es
wird abgedrängt auf der ebs wie auf
diesen bildern zu sehen ist europas
hilflosigkeit kommt dem türkischen
präsidenten entgegen er droht mit mehr
flüchtlingen nach der grenzöffnung hörte
das telefon nicht mehr auf zu klingeln
schließen sie die tore zu spät die türen
sind jetzt offen
im moment werden sie den anteil von
dieser last tragen die bundeskanzlerin
pocht gegenüber ankara auf die
einhaltung des flüchtlings packt bei
allem verständnis und bei aller
gesprächsbereitschaft die wir haben um
auch noch mehr unterstützung
gegebenenfalls zu geben völlig
inakzeptabel dass man das jetzt auf dem
rücken von flüchtlingen aus trägt doch
die odyssey geht erstmal weiter allein
auf der griechischen insel lesbos
setzten seit gestern mehr als 1000
migranten über dabei ist ein boot
gekentert ein kind ertrunken
beginnen wir mit unserem korrespondenten
an der türkisch-griechischen grenze
glück war port guten abend fühlen sich
die menschen die da nach europa wollen
benutzt ausgenutzt
durch die politik nein ich glaube die
menschen die wir heute gesprochen haben
und es kommen ja weiter hier welche an
die folgen einfach sie suchen einen
ausweg aus ihrer not sie haben gehört
dass die türkei die grenze geöffnet
haben hat sie haben noch nicht wirklich
mitbekommen dass auf der anderen seite
ist kein weg durch gibt aber das spricht
sich rum vor allem in den sozialen
netzwerken wir haben auch erste familien
gesehen heute die zurückgekommen sind
von der grenze weil sie einfach gesagt
haben das ist jetzt die zweite nacht wo
wir große gewalt erlebt haben an dieser
grenze mit tränengas und militärischen
mitteln und das tun wir unseren kindern
nicht an aber hinter mir hier im
streifen etwa ein kilometer sind noch
mehrere tausend die immer noch versuchen
hinüber zu kommen nach griechenland vor
einer halben stunde eine familie aus
hama 21 menschen mit kleinkindern
sie sagen in syrien geht es nicht da
fallen bomben auf uns die türkei wollen
wir uns nicht mehr wir suchen einen weg
gucken wir auf die politik mit stefan
leifert in brüssel stefan menschen auf
der suche nach einem besseren leben aber
auch politische interessen
menschenunwürdige zustände an der grenze
wie will die
das alles ändert ja so zynisch das auch
klingt die humanitäre lage der
flüchtlinge auf türkischer seite ist im
moment nicht so sehr die priorität der
eu sondern vielmehr die effektivität des
grenzschutzes auf griechischer seite als
symbol dafür kann man auch den morgigen
besuch der drei eu präsidenten an der
griechisch-türkischen grenze
interpretieren auch ursula von der leyen
wird dabei sein
dieser besuch soll eine
solidaritätsbekundung sein für den
griechischen grenzschutz für die
griechische regierung weniger für die
flüchtlinge die dort gestrandet sind
die eu steht in diesen tagen vor den
trümmern ihrer gescheiterten
migrationspolitik den kleinen erfolgen
beim gemeinsamen grenzschutz steht die
große uneinigkeit bei allen fragen der
asylpolitik gegenüber
nach fünf jahren ist es nach wie vor
nicht gelungen hier irgendwelche
fortschritte zu erzielen
es gibt im moment diplomatie auf allen
ebenen jeder flüchtling der im moment
von griechenland hinein in die eu
gelangen würde ist eine erinnerung an
diese uneinigkeit am mittwoch gibt es
ein sondertreffen der innenminister am
donnerstag der außenminister alles dient
im moment nur einem ziel den
migrationsdruck an den außengrenzen
irgendwie abzufedern hat sich ein dank
an unsere beiden korrespondenten und
damit in dieser sendung zum zweiten
großen thema heute der kampf der welt
gegen das corona virus die
weltgesundheitsorganisation sagt am
meisten sorge mache die lage in italien
iran südkorea und japan wo die zahlen
der infektionen teils stark steigen
in italien hat es 18 neue todesfälle
gegeben innerhalb eines tages und über
300 registrierte neu infizierte in
deutschland hat das robert koch institut
das risiko für die gesundheit
hochgestuft auf mäßig volker dutschek
berichtet die kleinstadt gangl dem kreis
heinsberg in nordrhein westfalen sucht
die normalität hier gibt es bundesweit
die meisten corona fälle alle angesteckt
bei einer karnevalssitzung eine
turnhalle ist jetzt vorübergehend
diagnose zentrum hier können sich die
testen lassen die fürchten das virus zu
haben dadurch soll auch das personal in
den arztpraxen geschützt werden
wir haben also auch in absprache mit dem
ministerium jetzt ein mobiles labor
zentrum eingerichtet um einfach die
hausarztpraxen von der test entnahme zu
ende
der aufwand um das ganze unter
entsprechenden bedingungen und
entsprechendem schutz über die bühne zu
bringen ist für die einzelnen
hausarztpraxis enorm hoch quarantäne hat
auch bmw mitarbeiter nennen münchen
verordnet dem forschungs und
entwicklungszentrum ist ein mitarbeiter
positiv getestet worden
150 kollegen müssen jetzt zwei wochen zu
hause bleiben
bei den hausärzten geben sich die
patienten die klinke in die hand nicht
nur bei eckert lummert in uetze bei
hannover
viele mediziner liegen extraschichten
ein und patienten mit corona symptomen
zu behandeln
und wenn die patienten in die praxis
kommen dann aber nur zu separater zeit
und vor allem in geschützten räumen ohne
kontakt zu dritten unter schutzkleidung
und auch er atemschutz
bundeskanzlerin merkel gibt schon seit
tagen keine mehr die hand aus
hygienegründen bei innenminister
seehofer wollte sie heute reflexartig
eine ausnahme machen
der lehnte aber höflich ab eine
besondere pressekonferenz von
wissenschaftlern gesundheitsbehörden und
dem bundesgesundheitsminister heute es
gab viele fragen die auch widerspiegeln
wie viel unsicherheit bei vielen
menschen in deutschland herrscht und es
gab das bemühen bei den verantwortlichen
für den deutschen kampf gegen korona
sorgen zunehmen britta spiekermann mit
mehr dazu selbst regierungssprecher
steffen seibert musste auf der treppe
draußen warten eigentlich sollte er mit
seiner pressekonferenz schon längst dran
sein
doch drinnen gibt es sehr viele fragen
zum corona virus an minister sparen und
experten diese bemühen sich um
sachlichkeit
wir haben mit dem stand heute morgen 8
uhr 150 labor bestätigte fälle
die meisten fälle finden wir zurzeit in
nordrhein westfalen da sind es 86 fälle
in baden württemberg und bei in baden
württemberg sind es 19 und in bayern 26
fälle
wichtig sei jetzt die geschwindigkeit
der ausbreitung zu bremsen
abschottung sei jedoch kein rezept ich
bin sehr froh darüber dass er ihm
gemeinsam gesagt haben dass und das sehe
ich weiterhin eine woche später so dass
das schließen von grenzen oder das
beschränken der reisefreiheit in der
keine angemessene und verhältnismäßige
entscheidung wäre die experten
versuchten auf eine große verunsicherung
in der bevölkerung zu reagieren
wir haben viele milde fälle dieses
dieser erkrankung ist eine milde
erkrankung das ist eine erkältung in
erster linie einer erkältung die unteren
atemwege betrifft und die ist im prinzip
für den einzelnen gar kein problem also
wenn ich eine erkältung kriege dann
werde ich das nicht nur überleben
sondern ich werde im normalfall sogar
relativ wenig davon merken aber für die
gesellschaft ist ein großer unterschied
ob alle diese fälle auf einmal kommen
oder ob die sich über lange zeit aus
denen es bleiben die empfehlungen an die
bevölkerung kein händeschütteln abstand
halten größere enge veranstaltungen
meiden eine kaum lösbare
gesellschaftliche herausforderung
experten also mit neuen informationen zu
risiken und maßnahmen in sachen corona
virus in unserem live blog zum virus
können sie die ganze pressekonferenz
noch mal sehen im internet auf heute de
und in der heute app der
integrationsgipfel im kanzleramt heute
mit verschiedenen migrantenverbänden
stand unter dem eindruck der
rechtsextremen und rassistischen
anschläge der vergangenen monate
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel erinnerte
an die opfer sie mahnte jeder mensch
müsse sich in deutschland sicher fühlen
können
zukünftig soll sich ein eigener
kabinettsausschuss mit dem kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus und rassismus
beschäftigen
in zwei tagen folgt dem thüringen ein
neuer anlauf zur wahl eines
ministerpräsidenten die afg schickt dann
ihren landespartei und fraktionschef von
höcker ins rennen einen der wortführer
des rechtsextremen flügels in der afd
er tritt damit gegen bodo ramelow an ex
ministerpräsident der linken ramelow aus
rot- rot-grünes wunschbündnis hat im
landtag keine mehrheit
er hofft auf stimmen aus den reihen von
cdu und fdp in israel wählen die
menschen heute ein neues parlament zum
dritten mal innerhalb von nur einem jahr
ergebnis waren bislang immer wieder
pattsituationen und deshalb kam keine
mehrheitsfähige koalition zustande
bei der letzten wahl
sam ballack herausforderer benny gantz
mit seinen mitte bündnis knapp vor dem
rechtsgerichteten likud block von
ministerpräsident benjamin netanjahu
laut umfragen liegen beide jetzt wieder
etwa gleich auf eine anklage wegen
betrugs und korruption scheint netanjahu
nicht zu schaden
aus israel katrin eigendorf gute
stimmung im tel aviver jemenitischen
viertel auch wenn sie heute schon zum
dritten mal innerhalb von elf monaten
wählen baby oder nicht baby das ist die
entscheidende frage die frage die die
israelis spaltet die wirtschaft boomt
guck mal das schöne israel wir haben
sicherheit das baby ein guter politiker
ist und erfolge gebracht hat kann man
nicht leugnen aber irgendwann muss auch
mal schluss sein
für netanjahu steht viel auf dem spiel
trotz korruptionsvorwürfen er will an
der macht bleiben und israel steckt in
der sackgasse der am längsten amtierende
premierminister der geschichte israels
hat durch seine machtbesessenheit das
land ein jahr lang gelähmt seinen
anhängern ist es egal dass in zwei
wochen bereits hier in jerusalem der
prozess wegen korruption gegen ihn
beginnt einen rücktritt hatte er
ausgeschlossen
und so wird diese wahl nicht nur zum
referendum über netanyahu sondern auch
eine richtungsentscheidung wie die
gesellschaft zu ihren rechtsstaatlichen
und demokratischen werten steht
er wirbt mit dem politischen wandel
benny gantz will israels künftiger
premierminister werden bislang fehlen
ihm die notwendigen stimmen für eine
regierungsbildung die wahlbeteiligung
ist heute unerwartet hoch sollte keiner
der beiden politischen blöcke heute auf
61 mandate kommen wird es eine vierte
wahl geben so eine lange nacht beim
auszählen
die digitalisierung könnte schon in fünf
jahren für so viel co2 ausstoß
verantwortlich sein wie der weltweite
autoverkehr sagt umweltministerin svenja
schulze und fordert deutlich mehr
klimaschutz und recycling beispiel
smartphone da soll die nutzungsdauer
steigen indem es länger software updates
gibt und akkus leichter ausgetauscht
werden können fordert die ministerin
dazu diese zahlen in deutschen
schubladen liegen weit mehr als 100
millionen althandys herum voll mit
rohstoffen
gleichzeitig kauften die deutschen jedes
jahr mehr als 20 millionen neue
smartphones sven regn berichtet sodom
nennen die ghanaer die größte elektro
schrott deponie der welt hier landet vom
pc bis handyakku der hardware müll der
westlichen welt die verursacher
unbekannt
das aber könnte sich ändern mit einer
technik die block chain heißt die würde
zum beispiel das leben eines akkus
lückenlos nachverfolgen
jeder manipulationsversuch in dieser
daten kette viele sofort auf wenn diese
akkus später dann auftaucht vielleicht
auf einer illegalen mülldeponie
dann kann ich zurück verfolgen wer war
der jetzt letzte in der transaktion
scatter der hier offensichtlich
missbrauch getrieben hat diese technik
soll kommen genauso wie grüner strom für
die rechenzentren so sieht es die
umweltpolitische digital agenda vor
alle betreiber sollen demnach bis 2021
standort und verbrauch der server melden
auch die verbraucher können etwas tun
strom sparen beim videos streamen etwa
was ist eigentlich als
standardeinstellung das social media und
auf den videoportalen die autoplay
funktion eingestellt warum die höchste
auflösung selbst wenn man das video nur
auf dem kleinen handy-display anschaut
außerdem fordert die ministerin dass
handys wieder reparierbar werden müssen
akkus sollen austauschbar seien alles
forderungen die längst überfällig sind
finden umweltschützer bislang hat die
politik das mehr oder weniger
verschlafen deswegen haben wir mit
unserer kampagnen auch immer direkt die
konzerne angesprochen die setzen das
sehr viel schneller rum
die digital agenda soll den
ressourcenhunger in der it stoppen die
anwendungen bewusster machen gemeinsam
ein stream schauen ist schöner und spart
energie und damit sind wir bei kristin
otto und dem sport genau und der großen
sorge im fussball spielabbruch in der
bundesliga durch proteste der fans nicht
ausgeschlossen bleiben die
schiedsrichter konsequent wäre bei der
dritten entgleisung auf den tribünen
schluss das problem die kommunikation
zwischen fans vereinen und dfb ist arg
gestört
der spieltag endet gestern in berlin
sowie am samstag historische wellen
geschlagen hat mit einer frontlinie
zwischen fans und vereinen in weiteren
drei stadien schmähungen speziell gegen
hoffenheim sponsor dietmar hopp der
ursprung dortmunder fans machten
wiederholt 2011 hopp als sinnbild für
den kommerz im fußball aus hoffenheim
antwortete damals ging dortmund mit
getöse aus lautsprechern
eine kontroverse ohne linie erst wurden
vom dfb kollektivstrafen für fans
abgeschafft jetzt sind sie wieder da nun
haben sich am wochenende deshalb ultras
in den stadien solidarisierte weil in
diesem jahr kollektivstrafen vom dfb
wiederholt gegen dortmunder fans
verhängt wurden
die kommunikation zwischen fans und
verein gestört und die mittel des
protests bleiben respektlos weil sich
hass banner gegen eine einzelperson
richten es gibt kritikwürdige zustände
auch im deutschen fußball die
anzusprechen auch drastisch auch
zugespitzt das muss also mache ja gerade
ultras das machen auch ultras das machen
aktive fans sehen unter anderem auch
deshalb weil sie am stärksten betroffen
sind von bestimmten zuständen nur es
kann nicht über den weg der diffamierung
von einzelpersonen gehen die frage wer
behält nur die macht und stadion denn
die gefahr dass spielabbrüche drohen ist
größer geworden
real madrid im freudentaumel erste
triumph im clasico seit fast vier jahren
und nach fünf pflichtspielen endlich
wieder ein sieg
nach pass von toni kroos einen
prestige-erfolg gegen dauer rivale fc
barcelona beide tore in der zweiten
halbzeit die königlichen liebäugeln als
neuer tabellenführer
mit den ersten titel in spanien seit
drei jahren
[Applaus]
deutschlands neuer
handball-bundestrainer alfred gislasson
selbst beim ziel olympia teilnahme
überwiegend auf das bewährte team
verzichten muss er allerdings beim test
länderspiel gegen die niederlande
nächste woche und beim wichtigen olympia
quali turnieren mit der april in berlin
auf den verletzten kapitän uwe
gensheimer sowie rückraumspieler paul
fuchs ja und die muss man erst mal
kompensieren
kristin zieh dich warm an sie auch denn
wir schauen zum schluss noch mal in den
norden der usa auf das was ein winter
zustande bringen kann wenn der wind
mitspielt das hier sind häuser am rande
des eriesees eingepackt vom eis das
wasser des sees war vom sturm tagelang
gegen die häuser gepeitscht wurden von
dauer allerdings sind die frostigen
schönheiten nicht
laut schon wieder aber da muss eine
menge wegtauen einige schneeflocken
heute nacht bei uns morgen auch mal
sonne aller details hat gleich katja
horneffer das heute journal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka 21 uhr 45
fragen an den bundesgesundheitsminister
zu dem was deutschland tun bzw tun
sollte gegen das corona virus von uns
allen herzlich gerne bis morgen und
ihnen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das war ein
kleines stürmisches tief dass in der
vergangenen nacht hier bei uns
hinweggezogen ist jetzt hat sich hier
südlich der alpen ein großes tief ein
geklingelt und das bringt
neuschneemengen von bis zu 50 zentimeter
am alpenhauptkamm auf der alpensüdseite
und am westlichen mittelmeer gibt sogar
gewitter
die brauchen wir jetzt in dieser nacht
bei uns nicht zu befürchten da fällt
regen oder schnee und der schnee etwa
oberhalb von 600 metern
es kann gefährlich glaube seien auf den
strassen im sauerland richtung eifel
hunsrück schwarzwald und allgäu
denn überall dort sinken die
temperaturen in richtung gefrierpunkt
oder darunter bilder bleibt die nacht an
der unteren donau oder auch an der elbe
mit fünf grad morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 3 grad im
allgäu und 89 gerade dank des rheins an
der nordseeküste oder auch mal an der
elbe die regen- und schneefälle der
nacht zu morgen vormittag hier ostwärts
ab dann wird es im westen freundlich um
dieser freundliche streifen der zieht im
laufe des nachmittags weiter nach osten
und liegt dann zwischen schleswig
holstein dem harz der rhön und dem
schwarzwald im nordwesten gibt es
dagegen schon neue kräftigere schauer
regen und schnee regenschauer sind das
wechselhaft geht es in den nächsten
tagen weiter mal mit mir sonne mit mehr
regen und immer bei temperaturen
zwischen vier und zehn grad
schönen abend noch